[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 est la
une ce soir l'opposition sénégalaise qui
fait marche arrière la manifestation
contre le pouvoir prévue ce mercredi a
été reportée à une date ultérieure elle
a également annoncé lors d'une
conférence de presse qu'elle
participerait finalement aux élections
législatives du 31 juillet nous serons à
dakar dans ce journal
l'ambassadeur américain en libye en
visite dans le pays pour tenter de
débloquer la crise du pétrole depuis
mi-avril le pétrole est utilisé comme
une arme politique de nombreux sites ont
été fermés de force conséquence d'un
bras de fer entre deux gouvernements
rivaux les détails à suivre
le personnel de santé zimbabwéen de
nouveau en grève ils réclament une
hausse significative de leur salaire et
l'amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
harare à la fin de ce journal
la tension est retombée au sénégal
l'opposition a décidé de renoncer à ces
manifestations contre le pouvoir des
rassemblements interdits par les
autorités la dernière manifestation ni
juin avait dégénéré en heurts mortels le
principal opposant ousman sonko a par
ailleurs annoncé que l'opposition
participerait finalement aux élections
législatives du 31 juillet écouter
et nous sommes obligés d'écouter ce
peuple sénégalais
est propre là dans sa majorité a exprimé
un souhait c'est de nous demander de
surseoir pour faire les raisons qu'on va
évoquer
on est dans la phase des examens
scolaires aujourd'hui beaucoup d'écoles
ont fermé d'autres ont décidé d'arrêter
à midi on est dans la phase des examens
scolaires et c'est nos enfants qui vont
faire ces examens deuxièmement on est
dans l'art dans la période de la
préparation de la fête de la tabaski et
tout le monde sait ce que ça représente
au sénégal
je vous propose de revenir sur cette
journée au sénégal marquée par
l'apaisement avec notre correspondant à
dakar à lindau sept vents de dégel qui
semble souffler sur le paysage politique
sénégalais la coalition de l'opposition
et aux escales nuit de noce jusqu'à une
période plus favorable à ces
manifestations au 2 rue selon eux d'un
bouc une des leaders de la coalition ce
matin face à la presse à l'opposition
avait prévu des manifestations ce
mercredi à dacca date d'autres villes du
sénégal pour s'opposer à la décision du
conseil constitutionnel de bloquer sa
liste nationale des titulaires pour la
participation aux élections législatives
de juillet 2022 de son côté osman son
coin des principaux opposants à macky
sall estime que l'opposition n'a rien à
gagner à poursuivre cette stratégie
d'occuper la rue pour lui le principal
enjeu de ces élections législatives et
la question du troisième mandat du
président à macky sall a pour lui si
l'opposition est majoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale au soir du 31
juillet cette question sert à cause une
bonne fois pour toutes et est-ce que
nuit à partir et ainsi à ces élections
législatives avec sa liste des
suppléants où ne figurent pas les
titulaires les leaders de la coalition
elle appelle cependant à la poursuite de
la mobilisation à travers un nouveau
concert de casseroles il y a une semaine
le premier concert de casseroles lancée
par la coalition d'opposition étaient
précis vie à dakar hélas d'autres villes
du sénégal
en bref le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
a décidé mercredi de prolonger d'un an
sa mission de paix au mali une
résolution sur le prolongement de la
minus ma jusqu'au 30 juin 2000 23
rédigée par la france a été adoptée par
13 voix sur 15 la russie et la chine se
sont abstenues
le fait est suffisamment rare pour être
souligné les quatre chefs coutumiers du
burkina faso ont décidé de sortir du
silence pour évoquer et mettre en garde
contre la division du pays ces dernières
semaines des messages audio
orlan pardon et unique ont été diffusés
par des inconnus faisant planer des
menaces sur la cohésion sociale et
l'unité nationale les précisions de
notre correspondant à ouagadougou
fraboulet dari
cette rencontre inédite est la preuve de
la gravité de la situation sécuritaire
au burkina une crise sécuritaire qui
fait désormais planer des réelle menace
sur la cohésion sociale et l'unité
nationale ces dernières semaines des
messages audio orélans ethniques ont été
largement diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux faisant ainsi craindre le pire
il s'agit ainsi donc pour les chefs
coutumiers de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
face à la dégradation continue de la
situation sécuritaire au burkina la
situation est préoccupante
malgré les actions entreprises les
résultats restent en deçà des attentes
des populations
nous chefs supérieurs coutumiers et
traditionnels du burkina faso condamnant
toute atteinte à la vie à l'intégrité
physique
morale et physique de toute personne
quelle que soit sa race son ethnie sa
religion son ap ap ap politiques et
idéologiques
les chefs coutumiers met ainsi les
militaires au pouvoir devant leurs
responsabilités et appelle les burkinabè
à l'unité c'est une pression
supplémentaire sur la junte au pouvoir à
ouagadougou à quelques jours du sommet
de la cedeao prévu les trois jeux
prochain à accra au ghana
direction le cameroun ou au moins 32
personnes ont été tuées le week-end
dernier à bâle 1 dans la région
anglophone du sud-ouest du pays il
attaque aurait été perpétré par des
séparatistes anglophone selon un
communiqué de l'armée camerounaise ils
ont ouvert le feu sur une foule qui a
assisté aux obsèques du frère d'un
député on fait le point avec notre
correspondant à yaoundé marcel amoco
c'est une escalade de plus dans la
violence qui sévit dans les régions
anglophones du nord et ceux du sud ouest
du cameroun depuis plus de cinq ans
cette fois affirmé le porte parole de
l'armée camerounaise attaque s'est
produite dans l'arrondissement d'akwaya
frontaliers du nigeria dans la région du
sud-ouest selon le colonel cyril at on
pas qu un groupe de séparatistes
anglophone lourdement armé a fait
irruption lors des obsèques du frère
d'un député et a ouvert le feu sur la
foule avant d'incendier le domicile du
député et de mettre le feu sur le
cercueil du défunt une attaque qui a
fait au moins 32 morts et des dizaines
de blessés ce massacre survient au
lendemain de la publication d'un rapport
accablant de l'omg de défense des droits
de l'homme du barrage contre les
séparatistes armés anglophone l'accusé
de pires exactions contre les
populations civiles le rappeur documenté
fait état de viols d'assassinât et
d'enlèvements l'omg recommande que les
milices qui commet des exactions contre
les populations civiles ne soient
identifiés poursuivis et sanctionnés par
la justice
la visite de l'ambassadeur des états
unis à tripoli richard norland a mis en
garde mercredi les protagonistes rivaux
en libye contre l'utilisation du pétrole
comme arme dans leurs querelles
politiques les tensions entre l'est et
l'ouest du pays ont largement paralysé
l'industrie pétrolière depuis avril les
précisions de camille nédélec
alors que le prix du pétrole flambe les
etats unis sont à la recherche de
solutions le pétrole libyen pourrait en
être une le pays est doté des réserves
les plus abondantes d'afrique mais les
exportations sont régulièrement
déstabilisé par le conflit entre l'est
et l'ouest
washington a mis en garde contre tout ce
qui se servirait du pétrole comme une
arme politique
il est très clair pour nous que la
fermeture actuelle du secteur pétrolier
doit prendre fin immédiatement
et que la gestion des revenus pétroliers
libyens au profit du peuple est plus
importante que jamais
le pays est divisé en deux avec un
gouvernement à tripoli un autre dans
l'est du pays
des installations pétrolières de syrte
ont été fermés de force tout comme six
autres installations fermées depuis
avril par des groupes armés proches du
camp de l'est tripoli dénonce le prise
en otage des ressources pétrolières du
pays
alors que la trésorerie nationale en
dépendent
nous assistons à une crise de l'énergie
et de l'électricité dans notre région la
colère du peuple monte le peuple libyen
est de plus en plus frustrés des
pourparlers ont démarré mardi à genève
entre les deux présidents rivaux pour
organiser des élections dans l'espoir de
résoudre l'impasse politique et
pétrolières
non reste de l'actualité en bref et en
images au bénin le gouvernement met en
garde les groupes terroristes contre
toute tentative de recruter de nouveaux
membres au sein de la population l'armée
béninoise est déployé dans le nord du
pays confronté à une multiplication des
attaques meurtrières menées par des
terroristes en provenance du niger et du
burkina faso l'union africaine
préoccupée par l'escaladé de tensions
entre l'ethiopie et le soudan l'ua a
appelé les deux pays à s'abstenir de
toute nouvelle opération militaire
khartoum accuse l'armée éthiopienne
d'avoir exécuté en territoire éthiopien
sept soldats soudanais dans la zone
frontalière contestée entre les deux
pays et l'ethiopie accuse de son côté
des soldats soudanais d'être entré en
territoire éthiopien déclenchant un
accrochage avec une milice locale
l'état de santé de l'ancien président
angolais jose eduardo dos santos jugé à
préoccupant il a été hospitalisé dans
une clinique de barcelone en espagne
déclarations de l'actuel chef de l'état
joao lorenzo en marge d'un déplacement
au portugal âgé de 79 ans josé eduardo
dos santos a été placé en soins
intensifs la semaine dernière
pour finir je vous emmène au zimbabwe où
le personnel de santé est à nouveau en
grève
leurs revendications sont claires il
demande à décupler leurs salaires et
améliorer leurs conditions de travail
dans un pays rongé par l'inflation
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux dans
le pays caroline dumay et stéphane
carstens
les patients qui se sont rendus à
l'hôpital d'art art et ont trouvé portes
closes la semaine dernière quand pendant
cinq jours consécutifs une nouvelle
grève des infirmiers s'est avéré très
suivie certains aides soignants ne gagne
que 50 euros par mois le gouvernement
propose de doubler les salaires mais le
geste paraît insuffisant dans un pays où
l'inflation est de 130 %
on a essayé de négocier avec notre
employeur
ça fait quatorze mois maintenant et même
en tant qu'association on a écrit au
secrétaire permanent mais on attend et
on a toujours rencontré personne pour
discuter de tout ça
aux personnels de santé affirme qu'il
n'a pas les médicaments de base pour
travailler il n'y a aucun équipement
pour détecter les cancers le
gouvernement promet de leur venir en
aide
nous avons montré notre bonne foi en
acceptant de les payer 175 $ en dollars
américains
le personnel de santé ne veut plus être
payés en dollars zimbabwéens pour la
porte parole de l'opposition le
dysfonctionnement des hôpitaux est le
résultat de décennies de mauvaise
gouvernance la corruption
la corruption l'échec dans les choix
financiers le manque d' expertise il n'y
a aucun spécialiste de la santé au sein
du ministère toutes ces choses ont
contribué à cette crise
les infirmiers zimbabwéen assurent
qu'ils continueront la grève si le
gouvernement ne le rassure pas un
salaire de 500 euros dans les prochaines
semaines
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena merci à vous de nous être
fidèles restés avec nous l'info continue
sur france 24
[Musique]
en octobre 2018 l'augmentation des prix
du carburant est à l'origine d'un
mouvement social spontané et gilet jaune
presque quatre ans après le début des
manifestations
les rassemblements ont encore lieu sous
le même étendard mais sans la même
résonance ce qu'on a gagné la danse et
qu'on arrivait quand même énormément de
conscience profondément anti macron les
gilet jaune se bat pour l'amélioration
du niveau de vie des classes populaires
certains auront laissé une partie
d'eux-mêmes dans cette lutte une seconde
j'ai perdu un oeil
une identité de la fois la chute des
figures et des retours chez les gilet
jaune à retrouver sur france 24 et
france 24 points comme
[Musique]
on a
deux
[Musique]
énormes
m